Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk a bit about the
glory and the woes of cloth simulation programs.
In these simulations, we have several 3D models
of garments that are built from up to several
hundreds of thousands of triangles.
And as they move in time, the interesting
part of the simulation is whenever collisions
happen, however, evaluating how these meshes
collide is quite difficult and time consuming.
Basically, we have to tell an algorithm that
we have piece of cloth with a hundred thousand
connected triangles here, and another one
there, and now, have a look and tell me which
collides with which and how they bend and
change in response these forces.
And don’t forget about friction and repulsive
forces!
Also, please, be accurate because every small
error adds up over time, and, do it several
times a second so we can have a look at the
results interactively.
Well, this is a quite challenging problem.
And it takes quite long to compute, so much
so that 70-80% of the total time taken to
perform the simulation is spent with doing
collision handling.
So how can we make it not take forever?
Well, one way would be to try to make sure
that we can run this collision handling step
on the graphics card.
This is exactly what this work does, and in
order to do this, we have to make sure that
all these evaluations can be performed in
parallel.
Of course, this is easier said than done.
Another difficulty is choosing the appropriate
time steps.
These simulations are run in a way that we
check and resolve all of the collisions, and
then, we can advance the simulation forward
by a tiny amount.
This amount of called a time step, and choosing
the appropriate time step has always been
a challenge.
You see, if we set it to too large, we will
be done faster and compute less, however,
we will almost certainly miss some collisions
because we skipped over them.
The simulation may end up in a state that
is so incorrect that it is impossible to recover
from, and we have to throw the entire thing
out.
If we set it to too low, we get a more robust
simulation, however, it will take many hours
to days to compute.
To remedy this, this technique is built in
a way such that we can use larger time steps.
That’s excellent news.
Also, the collision computation part is now
up to 9 times faster, and if we look at the
cloth simulation as a whole, that can be made
over 3 times faster.
As you see here, this is especially nice because
we can test how these garments react to our
manipulations at 8-10 frames per second.
If you have a closer look at the paper, you
will also find another key observation which
states that most of the time, only a small
subregion of the simulated cloth undergoes
deformation due to response forces, and this
knowledge can be kept track of, which contributed
to cutting down the simulation time significantly.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!